وسط احتدام المعارك على الارض في دنياتك
نشرت وكاله الاعلام الروسيه مقطع فيديو تم
التقاطه بطائره بدون طيار اظهر حجم الدمار
والاضرار الجسيمه في مدينه باخموت التي
تشهد معارك عنيفه بين الجيش الروسي
والاوكراني منذ اشهر متابع
[موسيقى]
استكمالا لنفس العاجل الذي كنا اوردناه
منذ قليل هناك حديث كذلك عن ان الصين اذا
فعلا ارادت ان تساعد موسكو فانها او عواقب
ذلك ستكون وخيمه بحسب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي اذا سنتابع دائما وتبقى العين
على هذه العواجل ولكن نذكر بتطورات ما حدث
من قبل في مقابله خاصه للعربيه اكد الحاكم
العسكري والمدني لاقليم لوغانسك للعربيه
اكد تحرير اربع عشره منطقه سكنيه من سيطره
الروس فيما تدور معارك عنيفه على ثلاثه
محاور اخرى واعرب حاكم عن امله بوصول
الاسلحه الغربيه ليشن هجوم مباغت وتحرير
الاقليم
الوضع في اقليم لوجانسك حاليا حررنا اربع
عشره منطقه سكنيه وهناك تصعيد على جبهات
عده لدينا ايضا ثلاثه محاور مهمه هي بايل
غورسكاو
يتصاعد فيها القتال بنسبه لروسيا انها
التجهيز الكثير من المجندين الجدد ولديها
جنود في لوغانسك والكثير من الاليات موجهه
الى خط التماس حيث تدور معارك وعنيفه فيما
تحافظ قواتنا الدفاعيه علم واقعها ونامل
وصول الاليات الثقيله الهجوميه من حلفائنا
في الغرب لنتمكن من شن هجوم مباغت ونحرر
لوغاسك
الحاكم العسكري والمدني لاقليم لوغان شدد
ايضا على عدم القبول باي صيغه للسلام مع
بوتين مع بقاء اراضي لوغانسك تحت سيطره
روسيا كما قال مشيرا الى ان الاوكرانيين
يرفضون المتجره بارضهم بحسب تعبيره
روسيا الاتفاق مع بوتين لا يعني شيئا فهو
يكذب دائما وكلنا يتذكر ما قاله عن القرم
ان جيشه لا يحتلها بعدها قال ان الجيش
الروسي لم يكن هناك ابدا ثم عاد يتحدث عن
الشعور بالفخر باحتلال قواته القرم ايضا
قبل بضعه ايام من بدايه غزوه لاوكرانيا
سالوه وقادته العسكريين هل ستندلع الحرب
اجاب كلهم لن تكون هناك حرب اي اتفاق مع
بوتين سيكون حبرا على ورق لانهم
سيهاجموننا من جديد ننتاجر باراضينا هذا
موقف واضح من الرئيس السيلينسكي
والاوكرانيين
نبقى دائما او يبقى معنا مفرد العربيه
احمد بجاتو من خاركيف احمد اهلا بك معنا
كنا نتابع هذه المقابله واتيت فيها على
اسئله
واجابك حاكم لوجانس بامور غايه في الاهميه
في الواقع لان هناك تصريحات يؤكد من
خلالها عدم
امكانيه ترك هذه الاراضي وكان هناك شيء
يحذر وكانه هناك
محاوله لطرح فكره ان هذه المنطقه تتسلح
شيئا فشيئا وبان ما طلبوا فيما قبل
مكنتهم اياه الجهه الغربيه تؤكد لنا ذلك
احمد
نعم بالفعل يعني حاكم اكد لنا هذا واثمن
بصوره واضحه الجهود ودعم الذي تقدمه
البلاد الغربيه لاوكرانيا واكد ان هذا
الدعم وفر تقدما او ساهم في حدوث التقدم
الاخير
وساعد على احداث يعني يعني ان توجع القوات
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه في كثير من
المناطق وتستعيد الكثير منها كما قال حاكم
لوغانسك لكن بصفه عامه يمكن قول ان هناك
مطالب اخرى يعني هناك حديث عن لقاء وفد
عسكري امريكي وحديث عن مطالب مزيد من
الاسلحه منها طائرات
مطالبات لا يمكن لا نعرف ان كانت ستتاكد
ام لا او سيتم تزويد القياده العسكريه او
الاوكران بهذه الاسلحه ام لا لكنهم يثمنون
بصوره كبيره
الاسلحه التي تقدم اليهم لانها ساهمت
بوضوح في ما تم احرازه من تقدم لكن
يعني يبقى الوضع في بخمه ربما يحتاج الى
اكثر من اسلحه ضخم تراها روسيا الان يعني
مساله حياه او موت بالنسبه لها تريد
السيطره عليها باي طريقه كانت لتنطلق بعد
ذلك الى باقي مناطق
الوضع فيها يعني كنت كان هناك فيديو يعرض
للدمار الذي طال هذه المدينه
المواطنون الذين او التقينا عدد من موطين
الذين هاجروا من هذه المدينه واكدوا ان
المدينه لم يعد فيها احد اطلاق المدينه
باتت مدينه فقط للمقاتلين من قبل الجانبين
العسكريه الاوكرانيه هنا حيث تتواجد انت
الان منذ بضعه ايام كانت مركزا للسادات
متكرره وانفجارات دامت لفتره طويله حتى ان
البعض تحدث عند مارتال كل جوانب هذه
المنطقه كيف هو الوضع فيها اليوم احمد
نعم اخر كيف يعني نحن كنا في خركيف وبعد
ذلك ذهبنا لكن هي احد الجبهات الهامه
والقويه
لانها تستهدف بصوره مستمره من قبل القوات
الروسيه والمدفعيه الروسيه التي تستهدف
هذه المنطقه لذلك هناك محاولات من قبل
القوات
نعم نحن هناك بعض العسكريين الاوكراني
يقولون ان علينا ان نتحرك من هنا ربما
الوجود هنا غير مسموح لكن دعينا يعني نكمل
هذا الحوار يعني
قوات عسكريه بصوره مستمره تتواجد وتاتي
الى هذا الطريق والتعزيزات وتعزيزات من
الافراد تتواجد لتذهب الى خاركيف للتواجد
هناك لان هذه المنطقه تستهدف بصوره مستمره
هناك ايضا حديث عن ان هذه السدافات اثرت
على البنيه التحتيه بصوره كبيره خطوط
الغاز والكهرباء المواطنون يعانون بصوره
كبيره الكثير من المواطنين الذين يلتقيهم
يريدون نهايه لهذه الحرب نهايه قريبه ايا
كانت ايا كان شكل هذه النهايه سواء
النهايه بتسويه بين
الطرفين او نهايه بارجاع كامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه للسياده الاوكرانيه
بهذا القدر احمد
اريد ان اضيفه رئيس
نعم رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه قال انه
عندما سئل عن مصالحه مع الروس وخصوصا مع
الحديث عن المبادرات المستمده قال انه لا
يتوقع مصالحه خلال 100 عام القادمه النظام
الروسي لن يتغير لذلك لن تكون هناك مصالحه
قريبه مع النظام الروسي نعم اود شكرا
جزيلا شكر وسلامتك احمد نلتقي في نشرات
اخرى مفرد العربيه احمد باجاتو شكرا دائما